[Music]
in arizona's southern county of santa
cruz you will find the city of nogales
at first glance an average american city
with a population of slightly
over twenty thousand most of these are
families of which the median income
lies at almost thirty thousand dollars a
year the average age is thirty four and
despite the many problems of the
american health care system the
population
is healthy there's a low child mortality
rate cost of health insurance is low
compared to the american average and
residents of nogales are healthier
than the american average unemployment
lies at seven percent
29 percent of the population have a high
school degree 35 percent have college
degrees and 32 percent have not finished
high school
the majority of the educated population
is younger than 44 and education levels
are steadily increasing by generation
what makes nogales stand out in the
american average is that the median
income is half
of the american average and that poverty
rates are twice as high as the american
average
with a population in poverty of 30
percent with this
nogales lies beneath the arizona average
but still does considerably better than
many towns in
other u.s states most working people are
employed in construction
retail and transportation founding a
business in nogales is easy and can be
done without having to pay bribes or
fear of being unnecessarily obstructed
by the government or organized crime the
city in fact provides a handy guide for
all the steps required on its homepage
intent to attract more business
several of the residents founded
businesses and bigger american
corporations
settled offshoots in the city the crime
rate is low violent crimes are rare
some crimes are non-existent and overall
the crime rates of nogales despite
occasional brief increases are lower
than the state average
and the national average the people of
nogales also have a say in the political
matters of their community state
and country they elect a mayor and a
city council that is accountable to them
and can be legally removed for
transgressions or electorally
removed should there be disapproval the
same can be
said of their state senator elected
through the second senate district
the governor and the federal
representatives they are part of the
third congressional district of arizona
with an elected congressman
accountable to them as well as a senator
all in all
political representatives tasked with
providing the basic infrastructure and
services a community need
to prosper who will be voted out if they
fail at that task nogales is by all
standards
just another average american city with
average americans living their average
american lives
but there is one thing which makes this
place
very special take a walk from the
mcdonald's down crawford street take the
right down arrow
boulevard and you might end up at the la
rochaba
which is in nogales in the state of
sonora
in mexico nogales used to be one town
founded by a cattle rancher family in
1841.
ten years later the americans bought
large parts of desert borderlands from
mexico and the line
drawn by that gatson purchase split the
town
in two
the average median income in dis nogales
is ten thousand dollars a third of that
just a few feet away
the percentage of people with college
degrees lies at eighteen percent the
majority of the population
don't even have high school education
educational standards are
so low that there is a local phenomenon
of residents
signing their children up in high
schools in the other nogales resulting
in a daily walk to school across the
border for many kids
housing conditions are bad some people
live in
shacks that lack basic commodities and
infrastructure
in large parts of the town drinking
water is contaminated by sewage
garbage and occasionally by industrial
discharge
the child mortality rate is high there's
a considerably lower average lifespan
and life expectancy
roads highways sewers and other basic
infrastructure are barely maintained and
constantly broken
many residents are forced to scramble
together and build their own
basic infrastructure such as access to
water electricity or sewage systems by
themselves
as both the federal and local government
fail to provide
basic services the crime rate is
high there are between two to three
murders a week three to four kidnappings
a week many local businesses are fronts
run by organized crime using public
transportation or taxis is an invitation
to getting robbed calling the police for
help might result in a considerable wait
due to the police being
understaffed throughout the state due to
targeted assassinations of police
officers who refuse to take bribes by
organized crime
resulting in fewer people being willing
to take such a life-threatening job
to top all that of saying that the
police has a corruption problem
is putting it mildly the state in
general is known to have one of the
highest rates of domestic violence and
violence against women in the country
the current governor of the state was
elected after her predecessor fled into
the underground
due to a massive manhunt and
international investigation for bribery
extortion racketeering and corruption
she is a member of the pri
a corrupt party that in collaboration
with oligarchs and organized crime
ruled mexico as a one-party state for
almost a century
her predecessor ran for a party
promising to end
that corruption but that party turned
out to be just as corrupt
and if you want to open a business in
nogales you will have to bribe
either the local corrupt politician
criminal gang dirty cop or even
all three of them for that privilege and
they might still
choose to rob you anyway and with all of
this combined
keep in mind that nogales on average has
a lower crime rate
lower police corruption higher average
education and higher standard of living
than the mexican average
ironically the only thing better in the
mexican nogales compared to the american
nagalas is the quality of healthcare as
the thousands of annual american
healthcare tourists can probably attest
to
[Music]
so why are the two nogales so different
what is it that makes these two places
that are only a few feet apart
so vastly separate in everything else
well why are some places poor and some
places wealthy
this is a question that many have even
more different answers to
and nogales is a great place to find an
answer
it isn't geography or climate as the
geographic determinist may claim
because both nogales share the same
geography and climate
it is not big business capitalism or
socialism
as both cities have the same class
structure and market system
it isn't ethnicity culture religion
demographics or some dumber people may
even claim
race because both nogales and majority
catholic
share similar demographics and the
population of the american nogales is 95
of what americans call latinos when you
boil
everything down to basics there is in
the end
only one single thing separating the two
nogales
a border this is a story about the
creation of state and economic
institutions
the failure of these institutions and
how the legacy of failed institutions
impact your life
when christopher columbus landed in what
he thought was india but what we now
know was espanola he encountered the
native peoples of the arawak
returning to spain he reported to the
king that the arawak
are so naive and so free with their
possessions that no one who has not
witnessed them would believe it
when you ask for something they have
they never say no
to the contrary they offer to share with
everyone columbus came from a europe of
war and conquest in which the idea of
sharing is caring didn't make much sense
so he concluded in his report to the
king that if he got enough
money to sail there again he would
return with as much gold as they want
and as many slaves as they ask and
hereby the tone was set for the first
mode of operation for the first spanish
colonists in the americas
sail over there enslave the natives
bring these slaves home and sell them
however upon returning to the caribbean
this plan didn't work
of the 500 enslaved arawak that he tried
to return to spain 200 died
and the remaining were so weak they
could not be sold for the fortunes that
he had promised so he had to make good
on the second promise of bringing the
gold and created the second mode of
operation for colonists he returned to
chichau in what is now
haiti enslaved all the arawak he could
find and forced them to dig in hastily
built mines in the mountains for any
scrap of
gold dust that they could find the task
made no economic ethical or even just
basic sense there was barely any gold in
hispaniola yet the spaniards would
brutally punish the arawak for not
finding any of the gold that didn't even
exist
in the first place the result was
rebellion massacre and genocide
within two years of the 250 000 arawak
half were dead columbus fell out of
grace with the crown but the
conquistadors had learned the new
blueprint
for what they would do in the spanish
caribbean instead of digging for
gold that didn't exist they enslaved the
natives and forced them to grow
sugar and coffee on caribbean
plantations starting in 1515.
however with this they encountered a new
problem by 1550
when of the 250 000 arawak only 500 were
left
they kept dying the brutality and
indignity of the slave plantations and
the extreme disruptions to their lives
killed them so they had to be replaced
at cost through slaves kidnapped and
shipped in from africa by the portuguese
the third mode of operating a colony was
thereby born
slave plantations with imported slaves
from africa it would spread throughout
the spanish caribbean and be copied
throughout british
french dutch and portuguese colonies
throughout the region
but as the spanish ventured further into
the americas they found another mode of
operating a colony a means of building a
society that would fundamentally shape
much of latin american social economic
and political structures to this very
day
in 1519 hanan cortes ventured into the
highlands of mexico and found something
that the spaniards had been looking for
for a very long time
[Music]
a settled civilization the aztecs did
not only have a state
taxation system division of labor
bureaucracy and empire they had a state
structure with castes from king to
clergy to warrior to peasants that
formed the foundation for the
institutions of their state to function
and that state was a feudal state with
an unquestionable set of god kings who
were in their power
absolute and unchallengeable here cortes
would do what had worked in feudal
europe for centuries before if he wanted
to conquer king
kill the king take his throne seize
control of the state
now you are the king and the state is
yours the aztec
emperor montezuma was kidnapped and
murdered cortes took his place installed
himself as the new
absolute ruler and acquired the wealth
of the state as well as the absolute
power of
its feudal institutions and although
these conquistadors did not become
kings in name they created a class of
colonial elites that pretty much
had the power of absolute kings by
taking over
from the previous kings and acquiring
the authority
of their state institutions the wider
system throughout the spanish americas
became known as the encomienda which
means commission
the conquistadors conquered the people
and then these people
and the land were assigned as an
encomienda to the individual
conquistadors
who then owned the land and the people
on it within a feudal structure
this structure remained in place until
the 1820s and was further expanded
through the import
of african slaves and spanish settlers
an additional development within
spanish-american society was the
development of the kachike which comes
from the arawak word
kasekwa meaning tribal chief kachikwe
today is more associated with the term
small tyrant it was used to describe
subordinate native american chieftains
who entered spanish society to retain
their social status
these kachikwis would then similar to
conquistador's rule
as small tyrants over stretches of land
and the people within it to exploit them
for their own benefits
and for the spanish crown as a result
society was expanded not just in numbers
but in structure by la casta
when european settlers arrived the
conquistadors developed into a
social elite that didn't wish to share
its power
the result was a class and racially
mixed feudal social hierarchy
nobles born in spain stood at the top
followed by nobles born in the new world
followed by poor whites born in spain
followed by poor whites
born in the americas followed by people
of mixed race
followed by india's followed by freed
slaves and at the bottom
lay the slaves a rigid authoritarian and
strictly hierarchical society
with stipulations in place that limited
any social mobility
this socio-economic structure would
remain in place throughout the spanish
americas for centuries and to some
extent
still to this very day the fundamental
purpose of it would remain to enrich
the motherland of spain only raw
materials were produced in plantations
and mines
brought to the harbours to be exported
to spain where they would be used to
manufacture products that were shipped
back to be sold to the colonies
thereby creating an economic system of
dependencies
there was no economic specialization
plurality
into other sectors or further innovation
worse still
it disconnected and disintegrated the
spanish colonies economically
before the spaniards there had been an
indigenous trade network stretching
almost the entire continent
with the arrival of the spanish the
colonies didn't trade amongst themselves
creating even further dependency on
outsiders
making spanish america an economy
dependent on foreign markets for its
produce and raw materials
and since the owners of the plantations
and mines were spanish nobles often born
and raised in spain and detached from
this land and its people
it started a sort of economic custom of
foreign ownership
of the economic structures of the region
a business culture in which these elites
who were the owners of economic assets
acted with impunity and complete
disregard for those who they considered
to be beneath them and almost
foreign even though they were in their
land
they would control these populations
with draconian punishments with a
foreign spanish army forbidding the
ownership of firearms and banning free
movement
and commerce laws which were enforced
through the iron fist of one of the most
powerful
entities in human history the spanish
empire
this situation also raised an increasing
resentment
amongst the wealthy elites despite all
the benefits they had
these only produced raw materials had to
sell to spain could not
trade with outsiders and could not
expand into and develop
other economic sectors with their raw
materials we will see
where this would lead to later meanwhile
in europe
there was a lot of envy and spite for
getting a head start the spanish and
portuguese had gotten the best parts of
the new world
the most valuable slave plantation
economies of cuba and hispaniola had
gone to the spanish
as well as the silver mines of potosi
the portuguese seized control of the
atlantic slave trade and the french
english and dutch were left with scraps
for their own slave plantations
consequently their early efforts focused
around seizing the enormous profits of
the caribbean slave economies for
themselves through piracy against the
spanish
grabbing whatever was left in the
caribbean and taking spanish slave
plantations by force
the lands in north america were left
untouched for almost
a century early spanish settlers quickly
realized that the output of plantations
in the north were only an eighth
of the output in the caribbean the north
was seen as inhospitable
uneconomical and wild but it was the
only thing
left to grab so by the 1600s the english
tried
and failed at roanoke so they tried
again in 1607
sent by the virginia company these
settlers landed in the lands of the poor
hattan in what we now know
as virginia and founded the place called
jamestown
in popular history these early colonists
are described as utopian settlers who
wish to build and farm a new society
and that is simply not true the
colonists had arrived with weapons and
goldsmiths
intent to do as cortes and pizarro had
done
kidnap the indian king seized control of
his kingdom and melt down the gold
however when they invited the indian
king
wahahun sunakok to an english crowning
ceremony at which they had intended to
kidnap him
his response literally was i shall not
take such bait
he then enforced the blockade of
jamestown the colonists had hoped that
the indians would
actually feed them after they had killed
and replaced their king as cortes had
done with the aztecs
so they had not brought anyone who knew
how to grow crops cure meat or even how
to hunt or
fish so they starved including all the
goldsmiths and resorted
to cannibalism indian societies of north
america were different from those in the
south
and central america the population
density in pre-colonial america was
lower in the north
and the peoples were organized in
semi-nomadic and loosely connected
confederations
there were not the masses of people to
enslave
farms and plantations to conquer goals
to steel
silver to mine and sugar to grow as in
the south but above all there were no
state structures and
institutions to take over the indians of
north america by and large
lived in stateless societies the spanish
model of colonization
simply couldn't work here james smith a
mercenary captain on the governing
council of jamestown realized first that
the south american colonial model would
not work here
he wrote to the virginia company to send
gardeners
farmers fishermen and artisans and since
the virginia company had made no profits
in the colony's two years of existence
they decided to implement a radical
change
the colony would no longer be run by a
council instead it would be run by an
all-powerful governor who implemented a
forced labor system amongst european
colonists and imported penal labor
the laws of the colony known as the laws
divine moral and martial
punished with death the leaving of the
colony the mingling with indians and the
theft of food
it also punished with theft the sale and
trading of any commodities and produce
made by the colonists amongst themselves
or to anyone except
the virginia company the virginia
company couldn't enslave and exploit the
indians so it tried to exploit colonists
in barracks with assigned food rations
and with governor ordered work details
they were to grow produce hunt for pelts
and produce
timber which they would hand over to the
company governor to be shipped back
and sold for company profit however this
also didn't work
who the virginia company sent to be
forced labor were people who were no
longer welcome in england
sometimes just pickpockets and drunkards
picked from the rabble of 1600s london
people who had little respect for the
authority of the english state let alone
some english company and in this place
the english monarchy had even less
authority
the imported labourers simply started
running away beyond company control into
the virginia frontier
they built their own farms their own
outposts their own trade networks and
they formed
their own militias instead of laborers
they became settlers
unlike spain neither england nor the
virginia company had the means to
enforce their order
so the tried and tested colonial order
of forced labor under colonial elite
collapsed
the virginia company needed a different
approach which they enacted
in 1619 they noticed that settlers
working
their own land produced more and worked
harder than forced labor
so from now on the virginia company
imported people as settlers and not as
forced labourers
to sign a contract according to which in
exchange for years spent in indentured
servitude
every settler was given 50 acres of land
by the company
and 50 acres more for every family
member a settler would bring
a general assembly was introduced the
members of which were voted on by every
land-owning man
which functioned as a counterweight to
the company governor
the settlers could still only sell their
products and produce to the virginia
company but the company and by that
extent the crown
could not simply force their will upon
the colonists
they had to govern through negotiation
concession
and ultimately pragmatism though
virginia would largely remain feudal the
governance structure that developed was
one dependent
on cooperation with the masses in 1632
the crown tried itself without the
company
when king charles the first gifted 10
million
acres of land around the chesapeake bay
to cecilus calvert the second
baron of baltimore who founded a town at
the bay and named his lands
maryland after the king's wife they
intended to create a society of plots of
land
owned by nobles shaped after the english
aristocracy
with surface to work and serve and just
as in virginia
it all failed there was so much land
that if you didn't like being a surf in
the lands you were assigned to
you could just move to other land and
lord baltimore didn't have the means to
evict settlers from the enormous
10 million acres of land he claimed to
own baltimore had to provide incentives
for settlers such as
a saiyan government therefore an
assembly was introduced
in maryland which voted to become a
colony of the king
thereby removing lord baltimore of all
power
in baltimore in new england a different
type of settler arrived
english puritans who specifically came
to build a new
utopian society detached from all the
legal and state frameworks of the
society they left behind
a kingdom of god in which religious
norms and communal values when forced to
keep peace in the virtuous and very
intolerant
society trade with any english companies
was a secondary issue to them
what mattered to them was the
construction of their new and
self-sufficient society
their communal values had priority over
not just individual liberties but also
the values and laws of the english crown
and these settlers would resist attempts
of total control over them
by england more than any other colonists
in pennsylvania delaware and the
surrounding midlands quakers mennonites
and
other persecuted protestant minorities
of england germany poland and
scandinavia
settled to build a pacifist society of
self-sufficient
small farmers people who wanted to be
left alone
and to themselves with as little
interference by any authority
in the south english caribbean slave
plantation owners
expanded into the carolinas and georgia
for more land for more plantations to
import more slaves into
these settlers saw themselves as the
descendants of norman english
aristocracy which they weren't and they
would build a brutal
slave society on a foundation of cruelty
and profit
these settlers may have professed
loyalty to britain but their main
loyalty
first and foremost was to their bottom
line
they implemented their own brutal social
system
built upon controlling a slave society
with ruthless violence
systematic oppression and cruelty and
they would resist anyone who challenged
that
socio-economic framework while the
appellations were settled by scottish
presbyterians from the scottish
borderlands and highlands
a people organized in clan and family
structures who couldn't give any less of
a dam about what an english
crown that they had spent centuries
rebelling against
told them to do they purposefully sought
out the hard-to-reach
borderlands of the colonies in the
appalachian mountains and forests
to be as far away as possible from any
english authority
and to live their lives as they saw fit
the social and economic structures that
developed were entirely different from
those in south america
spanish-american society was dominated
by an aristocracy
ruling over serfs spanish colonies
didn't trade with each other
and only exported to and imported from
spain
and that spain enforced its rule through
blunt military force
in the english north american colonies
the colonies traded with each other
specialized and even started
manufacturing themselves
built their own cultural social and
economic structures which were
increasingly independent from britain
a society of land owners developed who
had an ever increasing say
in how they were governed instead of
being exploited
by lords these landlords imported slaves
to exploit themselves or worked the land
themselves
for themselves which is a story
deserving of its own video
and far distant britain could only
maintain sovereignty
and rule over these colonies for
negotiation and concession
and as it would soon find out not
through brutal force
two very different social structures
started to develop in the new world
and as much as some know nothing english
twats with very posh english accents may
tell you that american society developed
out of old english customs and
traditions of monarchy
the reality is that it by and large
evolved out of a rebellion against these
things
but how did these societies develop so
differently and why
does it matter
while the english colonies started
taking shape a civil war raged in
england and during its chaos an
englishman called thomas hobbes wrote a
book about what he believed a state
should be called leviathan from which we
know that he would have disapproved of
what was happening in the english
colonies and would have preferred what
happened
in the spanish americas
the leviathan is an enormous biblical
sea monster before which all
human efforts to resist and fight are
futile
and in hobb's mind this is what the
ideal state ought to resemble
a powerful force of nature resistance
against which was to be
futile if all bowed before and
contributed to the establishment of a
powerful state that state would in
return secure the well-being of
all who were part of it that through a
collective effort
a collective good and security could be
assured
and also above all hold at bay what
hobbs saw as the only alternative
to the leviathan anarchy and
statelessness
whereas hops put it war
and described as continual fear
and anger of violent death and the life
of a man
solitary poor nasty
brutish and short the actual terror of
anarchy or stateless societies or
war or whatever you wish to call it
according to hobbes however does not
come from a continuous violence of
masses of all against
all but consisteth not in actual
fighting
but in the non-disposition thereto
during all the time there is no
assurance
to the contrary and a lack of structure
to provide
the passions that incline men to peace
are fear of death
desire of such things as a necessity
to commedious living and a hope that
their industry
will obtain them statelessness in hobbes
view could neither provide security for
one's safety
nor the security and stability for
industry labor
and commerce to exist and prosper what
hobbes proposed instead was a
commonwealth
state or great leviathan a collective
good and order that all would render
themselves under
its authority and would bring prosperity
and security to all
hobbes however was wrong the great
leviathan state and the whose authority
all shall render themselves
turned out to be amongst one of the most
horrific monsters ever to be inflicted
upon mankind
order within itself is no granter for a
universal common good
a powerful state with an efficient
bureaucracy can just as well use that
bureaucracy to create lists of people to
be deported
into death camps to facilitate depriving
a region of basic food supplies and
thereby intentionally starve millions or
create a society of surveillance and
mass policing in which nobody is safe
from the leviathan
itself power is in itself not an
inherent good
neither is being a state an inherent
good let alone are these guarantors of
social and economic success
a society of laws is only worth as much
as its laws are worth
and the leviathan that was the spanish
empire provided little prosperity or
economic success for its population or
security but more importantly hobbes was
wrong about stateless societies
stateless societies can exist and
provide both the security and stability
for people to prosper and
live the first communities of humans
probably started out as
family structures amongst
hunter-gatherers these would then
band together with other families to
form bands when those bands settled
during the agricultural revolution they
stopped travelling
vast stretches of land stayed put in one
place
developed myths and religions around the
landmarks and personalities of the place
invented stories in both identifying and
religious terms to explain their own
existence
developed unique cultural expressions
and through this
formed into tribes in these settled
tribes
the self-sufficiency of the
hunter-gatherer was abandoned a
segmented social structure developed in
which each and every one was dependent
upon the other
and each segment of society was a
replica of another segment the fabric
that holds these societies together is
family and social norms
traditions and religions such societies
are frequently romanticized as
anarchist utopias as places of freedom
solidarity and individualism places in
which terms such as prosperity
are meaningless as all prosper together
with the group alone through themselves
and their own
labor but are they
the new world colonies of england where
societies removed from the authority of
the english state
societies of norms traditions and
religion
and what were these norms traditions and
religious dictates
puritan new england was a deeply
intolerant society a place where quakers
had their noses cut open
ears sliced off and the face branded
with the letter
h for heretic so they could be easily
identified if they
dare return to their community a place
where communal judges handed out the
death penalty for adultery
blasphemy idolatry and sodomy a place
where captain thomas campbell
was put in the stocks because after
returning from a three-year voyage he
had publicly kissed his wife
in virginia the norms and dictates were
those of the landed gentry and
transplant aristocracy a place where the
punishment for insulting such an
aristocrat
was to receive 50 beatings by 20 men
have your tongue drilled through a fine
worth 10 years of a farmer's income
followed by being banned for life from
virginia
in the mountains of appalachia the norms
that dictated life were those of family
clans
feuding and fighting over scraps of land
and livestock with maimings
killings and subsequent retaliatory
actions in a cycle of continuous
self-propelling
violence and in the deep south the
social norms dictated that the black man
was a sub-human that the black woman had
no right to defend herself
against the violations of her body by a
white master that it was the white man
who has to be
both the owner superior and master of
all black men
because it has always been that way
because the bible says so and because
that is simply the norm
and tradition of the white man's
civilization a place where it was the
norm that the cruel
and horrendous fate befell black men
unfortunate enough to be accused of even
just
looking at a white woman the wrong way a
stateless society is a society of social
norms
and or a society of god it therefore
can be and is more than likely a society
in which the most fanatical
dictate what these norms are be it in
the name of king jesus or under sharia
it can also be a tyranny of cousins in
which arbitrary notions of family honor
frame your life's purpose and
limitations
it can be a society in which what the
norms are is dictated by the whip hand
and the bloodhound
in short a society in which what the
norms are is dictated by those with the
bigger guns
and it can be the society of the tribal
chief whose whims and neuroses
dictate everyone's life therefore a
stateless society can be every bit as
tyrannical
as horrendous and as cruel as any
leviathan
a society of fanatics violence and slave
owners that requires
every bit of obedience while watching
you may have started thinking over how
this is almost a metaphor for
interactions on social media where rules
are vaguely defined and the resulting
norms are dictated by those who
can scream for cancelling the loudest or
is it the other way around that social
media companies are domineering
dangerous leviathans
in whom we invest too much trust and
please
if you do hang on to that metaphor
because what i present here is not a
binary
state and stateless entities are known
to coexist
to cooperate but also to compete with
each other
the story of the united states is the
story of a loose
confederation of semi-stateless entities
that struggled over centuries
to unify and evolve from being societies
of
norms into a singular society of laws
a leviathan if you will but a leviathan
in competition
conflict and cooperation with its
internal disparate groups of
semi-stateless entities of norms
however more relevant for us is the
story of the spanish empire and the
americas
which as this video will show is the
story
of a collapsing leviathan
our common high school history
curriculum teaches us that the first
europeans to settle north america were
those
pioneers and pilgrims who landed in
virginia and new england
the framing of that story is within
itself not true but more importantly it
is overall factually
not true in the first decades of the
1500s spanish conquistadors had explored
the plains of kansas trekked up the
colorado river and through the grand
canyon
sailed up the coast of nova scotia
mapped the pacific coast from california
through oregon to british columbia and
ascended the smoky mountains of
tennessee a century before french
dutch and english settlers even arrived
on the eastern coastlines of north
america
in 1565 the spanish founded saint
augustine in florida which is the oldest
european town in the united states the
oldest building within the continental
united states is the governor's palace
in santa fe built by the spanish in 1610
the oldest building within the borders
of the united states is the san juan
cathedral in puerto rico built
in 1521. from 1560 onward the spaniards
pushed north of monterey to found santa
fe
and taos in new mexico pushed east to
found nagadoches
and pushed west to the bay of san
francisco the claims laid to the lands
of north america
were vast you will find the occasional
spanish enclave lasting to this very day
such as in colorado and new mexico
communities who still practice old
medieval spanish customs such as
symbolically crucifying a member of the
community during lent
communities that define themselves not
as mexican but as spanish-american
older than mexican-american communities
and the mexican identity itself
and fiercely defensive and protective of
their 500 year old spanish heritage
but spanish culture north of zakatecas
developed differently from the rest of
the colony
mexico or new spain as it was known then
was the crown jewel of the spanish
empire it produced
two-thirds of the empire's revenue it
was the most populous as well as the
richest part of the empire it was the
administrative
center of all of central america
northern south america and the spanish
caribbean which created a strong
governmental structure in its capital
silver mines as well as large
sectors of agriculture and ranching
created an economy and class of wealthy
merchants which built a society that was
wealthier than any other spanish colony
english colony french colony and by the
1700s even wealthier than the spanish
homeland itself
this wealth was hardly surprising if you
look at the wealth of the pre-colonial
americas it is also the natives who
lived in this stretch of land who were
the wealthiest
the spanish took over that society
expanded it
and prospered from it but to the north
of zacatecas
the environment climate geography and
society
changes the sierra madre mountains which
push out into
fertile plateaus in the south in the
north stretch out into the dry mexican
highlands known as the capiral
surrounded by dry lands and the north
american desert
these lands are dry with few rainfalls
during the summer the complete opposite
of the lush tropical climate zones and
jungles of southern mexico
mexico is a north-south divided country
in geography
but also in society southern and central
mexico's native populations were settled
city-state civilizations such as the
aztecs but go north and the arid land
made this type of settlement and social
organization
difficult here live the guar hiltekan
and the apaches
semi-nomadic hunter-gatherer peoples who
had adapted their society perfectly to
the land
they lived in and along the colorado
river you found the pueblo a settled
peoples who lived in towns and villages
of up to five-story high buildings
growing peach groves and trading in
textiles also
fiercely independent when spain arrived
it was easier to take over the state
structures of the south
then take the north especially the
apaches and pueblo resisted fiercely
these were not people who could simply
be subjugated and assimilated through
conquest and the usurpation of their
leaderships
they lived in these vast lands which
include the modern day states of texas
colorado
new mexico arizona sonora chiguawa
and guajilla and forget the modern
borders see this as a geographic
landscape
shaped by dry plains plateaus deserts
and occasional rivers
a rough land that required a rough and
specialized society
to live in the aztecs may have been a
society of laws
clergy nobles serfs taxes and
bureaucracy but those who lived here
were society of norms
traditions families and autonomy and the
spaniards chewed
that teeth out on them when the story of
the indian is told our modern perception
is dominated by a narrative of
tragedy that ignores their perseverance
at victories and victories there were
many don't know that in the wars between
natives and settlers the spaniards were
defeated in these lands
in 1680 after the spanish colonial
authorities burnt pueblo shamans on the
stake for heresy and resisting the
catholic faith the pueblo assembled an
army and kicked the spanish army
out of santa fe and new mexico the
spanish army may have been a modern and
terrifying entity on the battlefields of
europe but here in these
vast borderlands facing grier tactics by
an enemy who knew the land like their
back pocket they were hopelessly
outmatched
especially the apaches would not leave
the spanish
even a bit of respite burning mines and
ranches alike the apaches in fact would
keep fighting for
centuries against the spaniards mexicans
texans
confederates and americans alike and be
the last native indians
to surrender in 1924. the authority of
the spanish state
never really established itself here and
it never really stood the chance in the
first place
so what developed in its stead here in
the north
was very different the spanish called
native people
genthesin razon meaning people without
reason but unlike
other colonial powers the spanish
believed that they could be turned into
gentederason
and here in the north they would try
with a different mode of colonization
after the first one had failed for this
purpose the spanish established missions
usually run by jesuit catholic priests
the indians would be confined to these
missions where they would have to
convert to catholicism work in tanneries
mines workshops stables or kilns and
speak spanish only under the threat of
severe punishment
the native indians would be called
neophytes during their time in the
mission and the plan was for the priests
to civilize and turn them into
god-fearing catholics loyal to spain
and then release them however the
priests who ran these missions
made considerable profit with their
unpaid workforce
which consequently provided an incentive
to never actually declare
any of the indians brutalized in the
missions to be civilized
18 such missions existed in new mexico
20 in texas 8 in arizona and 21 in alta
california
and french explorers who visited such a
mission described them as
everything reminded us of a caribbean
slave colony
we mentioned this in pain because the
resemblance is so perfect
that we saw men and women loaded with
irons
others in stocks and at length the noise
of the strokes of a whip
struck our ears these missions would
form the modern towns of tucson
san antonio san diego and san francisco
the natives in essence were
slaves many consequently ran away many
more
died under the brutish conditions and
the spaniards had to import
more spanish settlers to continue
operations
consequently this new mode of
colonization
also failed these spanish settlers were
supposed to live
under the same strict rules and
regulations as were in place throughout
colonial spain
spanish settlers in texas were forbidden
from trading their goods with other
colonial states
even other spanish colonies like cuba or
california or to even
ship them from their own gulf coast
instead they were supposed to ship their
cattle hides down
cobbled roads to mexico city from which
they were then sold back to spain
a restrictive and highly regulated
economic model
intent on stifling any economic
self-sufficiency that could rival that
of the spanish crown
but it increasingly didn't work spanish
settlers simply left those towns
built their own ranches and farms and up
here in the north the spanish state was
simply
not strong enough to stop them these
independent and self-sufficient ranchers
tracked along the gulf coast into the
french colony of louisiana
to trade their cattle and leather with
the french merchants of new orleans
they would even sell them along the
coast to british and dutch traders in
open defiance of the spanish state and
its laws against local independent
commerce
just as with the english companies in
virginia and english aristocrats in the
chesapeake bay the colonial mode of
operation of conquest subjugation and
forced labor
simply didn't work in the northern
fringes
of new spain from texas to california
[Music]
the spanish had to provide incentives
for the cooperation of their subjects
they did so by offering payment in
exchange for labor in mines and
workshops
this created a wage-based labor economy
that spread
south from the north and gradually
started replacing the feudal economic
order of serfs and their masters
in the south this created an
increasingly wealthy class of merchants
while in the north
separate political orders and social
structures started to evolve
in the absence of the spanish state
people started
organizing in disparate communal
structures usually with the wealthiest
member of the community being at the top
that person
usually the owner of the largest ranch
or mine would become the benefactor of
the community
organize festivities provide charity and
settle disputes
the term used to describe and address
these individuals became
patron a divide started to develop
between a
south with its densely populated core
the seats of the government
and center of administration and the
north on the periphery
its society more decentralized and
self-sufficient
a divide that in many ways continues to
this day and is frequently ignored by
outsiders
a society of peoples who were distant
from the bishops
governors and tax collectors of southern
new spain
and spain itself where people married
without the approval of
catholic ceremony or priest where
different decentralized religious
practices
evolved distant from catholic doctrine a
society that became
majority white spanish settlers in
contrast to the large mestizo population
in the south
a society with a deep distrust of
centralized state structures
authority and government in which the
family and its
values and traditions mattered more the
north would significantly shape
mexican but also american society this
is the place where the wild west as we
know it in popular culture was actually
born
and not in the united states it was here
where the first
cowboys called vaqueros led cattle herds
on trails to markets both
south and north their language permeated
across cultures to be found within
spanish loanwords in the english
language into which they were adopted
when american settlers started moving
west
a hundred years later and encountered
them lato
la riata chaparradas rodeo
vaquero
the americans merely adopted the
frontier
mexico was born in it molded by it
it didn't leave the frontier until it
became annexed
[Music]
it is really hard to tell why
revolutions happen
even more so retrospectively most people
who claim to know are motivated by their
own desired outcomes
for one there is never such a thing as
just one reason
a tunisian fruit vendor may set himself
ablaze in protest
but the reason this incident became a
spark that lit a revolution had been
decades of economic mismanagement
corruption police brutality state
repression a political leadership that
was both
out of touch and arrogant a disaffected
youth
unemployment foreign education the free
spreading of information through the
internet and the list goes on
the same is very much true here i could
spend an hour
talking about why the spanish colony of
new spain became mexico but i won't i am
pointing this out though because i don't
want you to believe that the reasons i
list in this short video are the only
ones
when spain built its american empire its
first and foremost
interest was gold and silver and that is
what it got out of the colonies later it
would add sugar and tobacco to the list
of imports from its colonies in the
caribbean
but everything else was mostly left
behind economies around
other products from leather to meat to
wood to all the other basic commodities
and raw materials that you can think of
consequently started to develop
and it was those economies that
contributed to a substantial growth of
wealth in the colony of new spain
to such an extent in fact that new spain
eventually became wealthier than
spain itself and that was eyed with
increasing
envy by spain when the bourbons became
kings in the 1700s started implementing
taxes and regulations to get its own
share of that cake it sent
companies such as the gebusquan trading
company to the new world to seize
control of these independently evolving
markets
this is when the first murmurs and
desires for independence began in the
spanish americas from argentina to peru
colombia to mexico the wealthy class of
traders and the newly formed social
elites didn't like
giving up control over their revenue
unlike in the british americas
enlightenment values and philosophies
didn't play as much of a role in the
american autonomy struggles
most revolutionaries were part of social
elites
elites who wish to first and foremost
keep their social status and power
and their conflict with spain originated
from that desire
one thing is certain the spark that lit
the fuse to revolution
happened here in europe when napoleon
invaded and occupied spain
spain then allied itself with napoleon
this resulted in the british brocade of
spanish trade on the oceans which
severely hurt the bottom line of the
spanish-american elites and consequently
angered them
adding to that the pro-napoleonic
spanish government
favored the abolition of slavery and end
to indentured servitude
the tunes of liberty that were sung by
france and consequently in a spain
allied with france were something that
deeply worried the spanish-american
elites
in 1805 the british sank both the french
and spanish fleets in trafalgar
greatly diminishing spanish naval power
and subsequently its ability to connect
and to police its american colonies then
in 1806 the british invaded the rio de
plata in modern day uruguay and
argentina where they
were defeated not by a spanish but local
armies
and militias that event showed the
spanish americans that they were capable
of building
an efficient and well-commanded military
force by themselves without the spanish
and that they were even capable of
defeating a powerful nation
then spain had enough of france rebelled
and
sided with britain against napoleon
which ironically
brought an additional crack in the
relationship between it
and its spanish colonies because
suddenly spain
ended its century-old trade embargo with
britain
spanish-american ports opened for
british ships and british cities
opened for spanish-american goods and
the profits kept
piling up as a result as a result of
that the merchants and elites of the
spanish americas
started asking questions over why this
embargo had been in place in the first
place
if it would return at the end of the war
and how much
more they could make if they had
sovereignty over their own trade
policies as colonies
or maybe as sovereign states
the napoleonic war in spain or peninsula
war was an exceptionally
savage cruel and brutal war a conflict
that left a million dead and the spanish
nation
in smoldering ruins the treasury was
empty and the nation was in debt
the administration and power of the
spanish state had collapsed the once
so mighty and feared spanish army had
been humbled and crushed by the french
the war had in the end been won by
gurillas and
a british expedition of scottish and
irish troops
spain was left weak wounded broke
and battered and in this moment of
weakness the spanish restricted
trade with britain again angering the
elites of the spanish americas and then
decided to squeeze
even more out of their colonies which
angered them even more
adding to that the post-war spanish
government formed the parliament called
the cortes
and demanded the introduction of a
parliament in a constitutional monarchy
with an end to all special privileges
an end to slavery and the abolition of
all special privileges in a feudal
society
something that was unacceptable to the
colonial elites
it would however be untrue to frame the
revolution that followed as a revolution
of colonial elites only
spain intended to restrict the power of
the catholic church in new spain
forcing spanish bishops upon the people
while local american priests
swelled in the lower ranks amongst the
poor who increasingly preached against
the power of the spanish crown
in religious affairs in the americas
throughout the lower classes
spain had exiled the jesuits from its
colonies who ran
most of the educational institutions
thereby attempting to seize control of
new spain's educational institutions and
in the north
a people and society who had already
much autonomy and who became
increasingly known as the northerners
and who didn't like being told what to
do by mexico city in the first place
wanted to be told even less by a far
away madrid that
now sought out to gain control over
their lives
the revolution that broke out in 1810 is
a complex and fascinating story one
which would
burst the frames of this video and which
i hope we shall instead cover in a video
about mexican history specifically
one day in the future what you need to
know for this video is that it was an
incredibly savage war a war of burning
towns
pillaged lands and massacres the 11 year
long war for mexican independence was
more brutal
and vicious than any of the other
american wars for independence
it left half a million people dead which
is almost as much
as the victims of all other american
wars for independence
combined the spanish were desperate to
not let go of one of their most
important
if not the most important colony in the
americas
and consequently fought this war with an
attitude of either achieving
total victory or burning the country to
the ground
which as they increasingly lost they
increasingly did
the mexico that was born out of this in
1821 was not a republic but an
empire a monarchy governed by the former
colonial elites who saw themselves as
the legitimate rulers of an enormous
empire stretching from the bay of san
francisco to the jungles of panama
but this was also a mexico that was weak
in ruins broken
unstable and absolutely not in any
position to enforce
any of these claims the people living in
those lands as well as outside would
take advantage of that
the newly independent grand colombia
persuaded panama to join its
federation and when the former spanish
provinces of central america declared
themselves independent as the federal
republic of central america mexico
invaded and occupied the place but could
never really establish
full control over it within two years of
independence the mexican monarchy
collapsed
a republic was born and central america
became the central american republic
again
which however itself was just as
unstable and eventually fell apart as
outsiders took advantage of it but that
is
a story that deserves its own video
eventually
the newly independent mexican republic
was ruled by a succession of mediocre
and increasingly less qualified
sets of authoritarian generals veterans
of the war of independence and by and
large
interested in maintaining their own
wealth and power politics in mexico as
well as how political power in mexico
was exercised and perceived developed
very differently from the united states
in the newly formed
united states politicians were
increasingly beholden to their
electorate as public servants
in contrast to that politics in the
mexican republics of the 1800s which
were in the end mostly military juntas
and dictatorships was about securing
your own power and interests
an elitist club reserved for society's
elites to squeeze what they could
out of the country the economic
structures that developed out of this
were also
vastly different in the united states
the economic structure that developed
was an inclusive and open one
a capitalist system in which anyone
could open business
and do business on their own terms the
economic structure of mexico when
exclusionary capitalism and its
institutions reserved for a select few
people at the top of society you went
into mexican politics as a wealthy man
to secure your assets and not
for the good of the community or country
mexico became the kind of country where
the governor of a state
happened to also own the largest mining
complex in the state his uncle owned the
largest
ranch estates of the state his brother
was appointed the chief justice of the
state his cousin was appointed the state
chief of police and his business
partners became the various ministers of
the state
a kleptocratic state structure where
personal interests of ruling elites
mattered the most the legacy of which to
large extent
continues in modern mexico to this day
mexico
in many parts still is a country where
people go
into politics not to serve their
communities and country but to enrich
themselves
not very different from the kachikwas of
the colonial era in fact
many of these powerful men were and are
a direct inheritance of that system
and there was one part of mexico in
particular where this type of government
system was increasingly
unpopular the north the northerners
didn't like being told
by spain what to do they didn't like
being told by colonial elites what to do
and they now didn't like being told what
to do but a new
powerful elites of mexico city the
natenos
lived for most self-sufficiently in
their communities of ranchers and
farmers stretching from california to
sonora to texas
they had a way of life that had evolved
throughout the last centuries that they
wished to keep and during the first
decades of mexican independence the
powers to be in mexico city also ignored
and neglected them
the sparsely populated lands of
california were attempted to be used as
a mexican prison colony
when california governors requested
funds and materials to improve
the few cobblestone roads that existed
mexico cities sent them
boatloads of convicts and kidnapped
southern mexicans to build those
however since california had not the
resources to control and manage
such these penal laborers tended to
break free
roam the lands plunder existing towns
and then settle out of reach of mexican
authorities
this prison labor system had developed
in southern mexico where when the state
ran out of funds for infrastructure such
as roads the government just used the
army to kidnap
thousands of innocent mexicans and force
them to build those projects
a system which was continued by mexican
governments way up into the early 20th
century
despite the chaos of the first decades
of independence the mexican state had
still
inherited the powerful colonial
government institutions of the spanish
empire
and could therefore still enforce this
in the south but in the north
just as with the english prison colony
system in virginia it simply didn't work
the best example of how destabilized
kleptocratic and broken
mexican governance was in the first 50
years of its existence is by following
the career of santa anna
santa anna was the son of a colonial
official and soldier in the spanish army
in new spain when the spanish started
losing the war of mexican independence
he switched sides and helped establish
the mexican monarchy he became president
of mexico in 1833 but after a few days
handed the presidency over to gomes
farias who was supposed to be
acting president while real power
remained with santa anna freyas however
was only president for two weeks after
which the presidency came back to santa
ana
who again remained president for less
than a month and then returned the
presidency to gomez faria the two men
continued this continual exchange of the
office of president
for two years which they did as part of
schemes to enrich themselves by 1835
the scheme fell apart and the different
son of a colonial official
and member of mexico city's elites
miguel baragan became president
however santa anna didn't quit and
became president again
in 1839 1841 1844
1847 and 1853 in total he was president
of mexico
11 separate times during his terms he
was
exiled from mexico five different times
presided
over economic kleptocracy over
substantial losses in territory and two
disastrous military defeats
in total between 1824 and 1867
mexico had 52 presidents none of them
were elected
all were members of the country's
business and military elites
all ruled through military juntas and
all spent their time and power
preoccupied with trying to enrich
themselves and their friends at the
expense
of the rest of the country over this
period of time mexico lost control over
large parts of the country the once
powerful government administrations of
the spanish empire started to fall apart
the ability of the state to enforce the
law decreased
taxes could no longer be efficiently
collected corruption was rampant
how and what laws were enforced was
arbitrary
and dependent on who you were and what
your social status was
within this society separatist movements
emerged in texas
and out of california that successfully
split off and several more emerged in
sonora
bayer california yucatan and along the
rio grande
the resulting revolutions uprisings
rebellions and civil wars without
counting wars with outsiders killed
more mexicans than american deaths in
all american wars combined and left much
of mexico in ruins as the government
sent out
armies to brutally crush and burn all
descent
in simple terms this was a mess a
complete disaster
a disaster that continued almost
throughout the entire history of mexico
throughout the 19th century
made worse by a french invasion and
occupation from 1861 to 1867 which
further destabilized the country and
eroded the institutions of the state
the mexican republic to emerge out of
the ashes of the war with france was
even less capable of holding it all
together
the economy was by and large owned by
the elites who created this mess with no
room for growth or innovation or even
just economic participation in
entrepreneurship
by individual citizens mexico is in the
end
lucky to even still exist as a
nation-state after the 19th century that
it experienced and that it didn't just
fall apart completely and was absorbed
by
outside forces that is not to say
that those outside forces didn't try
thank you for watching if you don't want
to miss the next part
about the mexican-american wars the
franco-mexican war and comparing the
industrial revolution in the united
states
and in mexico make sure to subscribe you
can also support this channel and keep
it running by donating to my paypal
or by becoming a patron don't forget to
also share the video around
with friends and family many thanks also
to tsunami music who made music for this
video
you will find a link to her soundcloud
and social media in the description
and many many many thanks also to
contributing artists
who came forward as volunteers to
contribute their artwork to this video
the turkish artists turkbud for making
the thumbnail and alp mapper for making
colonial scenes
the chilean artist flying tank for
colonial and pueblo scenes
the american artist ekko jacuzzin and
five dollar note for the prelude
colonial scenes and el norte scenes the
american animator jamie asola
for two great animations the polish
artist kovarat
for a leviathan scene the korean artist
teabag for redesigning the aztec ball
and great colonial scenes
the american artist vexysphere for north
american colonial scenes and who also
happens to run
a poland ball youtube channel the
malaysian artist mrs human car for
several colonial scenes
the norwegian artist pile of trash for
making almost the entire second chapter
the mexican artist nomad for several
scenes about northern mexico and who
also
runs a poland ball youtube channel and
the german artist tanet
for several scenes about the first
mexican republic
many of these artists are open for
commission or even run their own youtube
channels
if you ever want to commission art i
highly recommend you check them out
links to all their social media are in
the description also
many thanks to gunter liberal sanity
project
tingly voice and awful ophelia for
reading lines for this video
links to their channels are in the
description i hope to see all of you
soon again